Падіння цін на золото здається не зовсім логічним
на тлі останніх глобальних подій, відзначають експерти.
З початку року вартість золота знизилася більш ніж на 6 відсотків,
хоча у світі зберігається досить нестійка геополітична ситуація.
І за таких умов інвестори, як правило, намагаються наростити запаси золота, а не навпаки.
Немає занепокоєння на ринку, хоча кожен день у пресі обговорюється
і геополітична ситуація на Близькому Сході,
і торговельна війна між США, Китаєм та ЄС,
і деяка нестабільність, яку ми бачимо у зв'язку з Трампом і його твітами.
Серед інших причин нестабільності можна назвати боргову кризу в Європі та Брексіт.
Але чому ж, незважаючи на таку турбулентність, дорогоцінний метал втрачає в ціні?
Ймовірно, тому що багато хто розглядає інші можливості для інвестицій.
Наприклад, ще зовсім недавно криптовалюту називали серйозним конкурентом золоту.
середині грудня минулого року курс біткоіна досяг історичного піку.
У майбутньому можна припустити, що біткоін стане альтернативою золоту.
Але досі не можна стверджувати, що це так.
Тобто, у біткоіна є свої переваги. Є і свої недоліки.
Обидві інвестиції цікаві, мають позитивні й негативні боки,
але не думаю, що вони сильно взаємозамінні, і зростання біткоіна
має сильний вплив на золото і навпаки.
За останні місяці біткоін сильно подешевшав, і галас навколо криптовалют стих.
Золото ж ще покаже себе цього року, впевнені аналітики.
Вони прогнозують підвищення ціни на дорогоцінний метал.
Відбудеться це, щойно фінансові ринки відреагують на події у світі.
Ті чинники нестабільності, на які на даний момент фінансові ринки заплющують очі:
і торговельна війна, і політична нестабільність, і можливість, що ці політичні дискусії
матимуть значення для компаній і для ринків, і для економік світових.
І за цієї ситуації мати золото - це зовсім непогана ідея.
Тому я очікую, що ціна на золото вже цього року зросте.
Нині ціна на золото близько 1223 доларів за тройську унцію - це в перерахунку близько 30 грамів.
І, на думку аналітиків, може бути 1300 доларів вже за кілька місяців.